[Musik]
immer noch ist in diesem film geht es um
drei familien die ein ähnliches
schicksal teilen
sie mussten sich die für eltern wohl
traurigste und zugleich brutalste frage
stellen wie lange soll unser kind noch
leben
die frau kann die römische stelle so was
für die ohren zu ziehen die hoch also
wie lange überlegen vom leben hat sie
zueinander lärm kampf solange mir
zehnter leer und so lange mache mir
alles fragen wie wie zimmer mit wieder
beleben oder und das ist ja das ist
schwierig also ich bin froh wenn es wenn
es nicht minder entscheiden hatte
[Musik]
das probiere mal mitgemacht weil mir das
gesagt das habe doch letzte woche bringt
wie die meisten teenager legt morgen die
wert auf ihr äußeres im gegensatz zu
gleichaltrigen ist sie dabei auf die
hilfe ihrer mutter angewiesen sich die
15 jährige marga league ist
lebensbedrohlich erkrankt sie leidet an
rasmussen enzephalitis einer seltenen
autoimmunerkrankung die das gehirn
schädigt aus dem gesunden mädchen das
sie einmal war ist ein schwerst
betroffener teenager geworden sowohl in
kognitiven als auch körperlichen
fähigkeiten eingeschränkt im frühling
dieses jahres hatte magath in der
badewanne einen epileptischen anfall und
tauchte unter tage lang kämpfte das
mädchen im spital ums überleben
primark ist ganz kritiklos mit mir
schlafen gegangen ist oder über
spezielle zürich sie und geglückten
ehemaligen klaus und krieger nackt weil
sie zum interview aber das ist positiv
sehr positiv blieb und das nützt gar ich
finde es super dass ich oft laufe und
durch den ruhestand gehen wenn man auf
dem rollstuhl unterwegs sind das gerade
am anfang ist das gar nicht will und
dezent ist das ganz normal
familienausflug 28 die peters darauf
dass marlies krankheit ihr leben nicht
komplett dominiert doch mal ist zustand
gibt regelmäßig den takt vor mehrmals
täglich erleidet sie epileptischer
anfälle wie jetzt auf dem spaziergang
die familie hat sich längst daran
gewöhnt dass ich jetzt einfach das war
nicht belebte schaaf ist mag die hitze
dann häufig was auch wien ist es nicht
so dass sie wirklich eben gerade umgeht
oder schuhe mit aber seid einfach dass
dafür sehr oft dass er schwimmen kannst
du wirklich aber du bist mein geschäft
so abweisend durch seine absenz gaal und
dem staat mit derart stark sicher recht
wenn man einfach mal mitmachen das ist
das logo stufen ja und das ist ja eine
je nachdem ich das ganz häufig das ganze
ja eigentlich fast alle fünf minuten
naja dritte möglichkeit ihre das merkt
wenn man sich wenig metallica
[Musik]
die 13 jährige sharon daheim in ihrem
kinderzimmer
die eltern sind sich sicher dass sharon
ihr umfeld noch wahrnimmt
auch wenn sie nicht mehr sprechen kann
stets nur gebete sprachen aber jetzt gab
das klima und wir verstehen sie meistens
vom acker mann zu tode gekommen
seit zwei jahren pflegen die eltern ihre
unheilbar kranke tochter zu hause
sie soll dort wo sie sich am wohlsten
fühlt sterben dürfen jahren leidet seit
ihrer geburt an morbus pompe eine
seltenen neuromuskulären erkrankungen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
zwar war sharon durch ihre krankheit aus
kind eingeschränkt nahm aber aktiv am
alltag teil bis sie vor zwei jahren eine
schwere lungenentzündung liegt
mittlerweile kann sich sharon nicht mehr
bewegen muss künstlich beatmet und
ernährt werden
es geht ihr tendenziell immer schlechter
die eltern sind bemüht ihre tochter ins
familienleben zu integrieren
foto dan coats nötig sagen mein respekt
da ich aber so stark ist immer mit uns
zwei meter stube und zu mal waren es
schöne wetter richtung balkon aber
systemen mit uns zusammen das knust sehr
sehr gern so sehr gern mit uns zusammen
auch wenn diese momentaufnahme mit
kaffee und kuchen und dem besuch der
großmutter so friedlich scheint es ist
ein leben im ausnahmezustand für die
gesamte familie auch für terrence
jüngerem bruder mit dessen sind sich die
eltern sehr wohl bewusst keine ferien
keine familienausflüge nur selten
verlassen sie gemeinsam das haus kehren
zurück zu lassen fällt ihnen schwer
das ist natürlich wir sind natürlich bei
meiner familie nichts für mich
mehrmals täglich bekommt sharon starke
schmerzmittel verabreicht körperliche
qualen sollen dem todkranken mädchen
erspart bleiben
zur kontrolle im kinderspital zürich
magali besucht mittlerweile eine
sonderschule die krankheit wirkt sich
auch auf ihr sozialleben aus weil sie
merke beschlussvorschlag es stimmt nicht
was du für verwerter ps und alles nicht
so sicher schnell verstanden was los ist
für die schlachten fürs laufen so viel
besser sagt magali geht sonst in der
schule
[Musik]
die vielen der grund sei dass trugen für
eine umfassende behandlung magali sind
sowohl eine neurologin als auch eine
palliativ mediziner in zuständig eva
bergsträßer sie begleitet die familie
palliativbetreuung beinhaltet auch die
auseinandersetzung mit dem sterben
hauptsache mein kind bleibt am leben so
der natürliche reflex der meisten eltern
doch ist das tatsächlich immer das beste
für das kind solche und ähnliche fragen
gilt es zu klären
ja dass man zum beispiel auch fragt
woran erkennen sie dass ihr kind leidet
was macht das gute leben ihres kindes
aus was möchten sie ihrem kind zumuten
was meinen sie was ihr kind ertragen
kann
was würde ihr kind das ich jetzt nicht
äußern kann ihn übel nehmen
ich glaube das kann helfen um solche
wünsche die manchmal recht global sind
auch ein bisschen herunter zu brechen
was genau mein ich eigentlich bin ich
mir sagt das kind muss leben die eltern
reden offen mit marga die über ihre
krankheit
das thema sterben haben sie bewusst nur
gestreift sie wollen magali keine angst
machen die eltern aber mussten sich
gezwungenermaßen mit dem lebensende ihre
tochter auseinandersetzen wenn sie jetzt
sowie fällige e mobilität während sich
eine größere zu oder denn dann ist man
halt für sich entscheiden ob sie nur ja
und das ist ja das schwieriger so dass
die wichtige bin also fisch ist ein
kleiner macht einfach so viel wie es der
marke li nütze aber man merkt es geht
maßnahme aber man konnte hat dass sie
wieder belebt wird weiß sie könnte das
geschlecht herausfordern
da muss man sagen das machen wir lieber
nicht
[Musik]
es ist dass ich würde heute sind laut
der englischen namen
danke vielmals
ich komme was gilt im notfall eva
bergsträßer hilft familien ihre wünsche
in betreuungs vereinbarungen
festzuhalten
ein längerer prozess in dem meist
mehrere personen involviert sind
doch am ende sollen die eltern
entscheiden können
von externen ted was zu initiieren kann
höchst problematisch sein weil die
eltern egal was sie jetzt treibt etwas
zu tun oder nicht zu tun
sie müssen mit dem was dann passiert
leben und dafür sind wir auch ein
bisschen mitverantwortlich wie es ihnen
geht wenn ihr kind gestorben ist egal
wie es gestorben ist
[Musik]
ihre art der verarbeitung der sohn von
thomas und tiffany wermelinger ist vor
anderthalb jahren verstorben
zur erinnerung an ihn haben die eltern
eine ecke des wohnzimmers mit lebens
spielzeug dekoriert auch seine urne
steht hier die hayek sie und man
ziemlich schnell werde psa teil vor es
ist immer neue saison und das wird ja
nie andere und drum ich sehr schön jeder
doktor in lyon war mit 18 monaten an
leukämie erkrankt für den jungen aber
auch für seine eltern begann eine
intensive zeit der kampf gegen den krebs
liam musste sich mehreren behandlungen
unterziehen lassen erfolglos
die familie reist in die usa ihre letzte
hoffnung eine neuartige immuntherapie
die therapie ist nicht ungefährlich
das wissen die eltern der krebs
verschwindet zwar tatsächlich doch liem
wird immer schwächer
was ist mit maschinen der macht was sie
macht mit dem ist nämlich wenig ändern
und endlich realisiert man gar nicht so
drin und was nicht
den höhepunkt fand ihn ihr euch fragt
sind will ich mir ohne grundlos
logistisch sowie das machen
er hatte kontakt und erhard bestimme wie
das an gott
das hat niemand anders bestimme ich
glaube mir geht es gott wirklich tolles
und erleidet und so ich glaube dann
werden wir eine zugegangen aber ich
glaube er hat die therapie nicht
überlebt er ist im beisein seiner eltern
verstorben maschine weg no und alles
abhängt eigentlich musste schmerzmittel
das alles relativ ruhig gestellt also
sicher schmerzen muss also ja und dann
getötet und roxy und ja das eine dabei
entdecken wir kämpfen bis zum schluss
doch was ist wenn eltern das nicht
wollen können eltern auf das lebensende
ihres kindes einfluss nehmen
diese entscheidung können auch eltern
treffen dass sie sagen wir sind zwar in
der stabilen kontinuierlichen situation
es wird nicht besser es wird tendenziell
immer etwas schlechter wir wollen jetzt
zum beispiel die beatmung langsam
beenden und dann würden wir helfen dass
man das tun kann
die möglichkeit gibt es die möglichkeit
gibt das ist nie eine spontane
entscheidung die wird mit den eltern
langsam entwickelt wie als solche
prozesse das ist wichtig weil wir den
eltern so was aus dem affekt heraus
sagen und wir handeln
dann kann es sein dass sie schon eine
woche später sagen wir haben fehler
gemacht deshalb gilt es gut zu
gesprächen zu sagen wir haben
miteinander beschlossen dass es jetzt
gut ist wir können die therapie beenden
oder die therapie die lebenserhaltenden
maßnahmen
das ist es ja eigentlich von selbst wäre
ein kind wären schon längst gestorben
heute rennt
der buch macht visite der
palliativmedizin des zürcher
kinderspitals bei tieren zu hause
im moment mache ich mir sorgen um die
bucht ist dann kriterium ist ja
hausbesuche ermöglichen der ärztin sich
ein bild über trance zustand zu machen
um anschließend mit den eltern die
nächsten schritte zu besprechen wo sage
dir
es gibt einen punkt wo mir ergeht es ihm
geht es nicht sagt okay jetzt geht es
nicht mehr und wenn es kommt ist das
zieht barisch dann schaut sie da uns
verabschieden aber mir vor dass das land
machen und an das gefühl sie hatten
urlaub ist qualität
ja also wie sich mein bruder auf dem
schläger
das wundert uns alle so gemacht
für eine optimale medizinische
versorgung sharons arbeiten die ärztin
und das team der kickbacks hand in hand
die kinder spitex kanton zürich
unterstützt und begleitet die familie
während der sogenannten end of life
phase und ermöglicht das sharen trotz
komplex palliativer situation daheim
versorgt werden kann
zum hilfsangebot gehört auch die
medizinische überwachung während danach
die eltern möchten ihre tochter
unbedingt bei ihrem letzten schritt
begleiten
der vater ist in sorge er schaffe es von
der arbeit nicht rechtzeitig nach hause
meine hoffnung ist dass ich zu bieten
trotz schwieriger moment sondern wenn
das passiert aber ich wollte für meine
tochter gewesen
das sonett iii ist auch etwas das ist
das wichtigste für mich
das ist nicht das mittel mit dem
früheren daran immer gesagt dass ich
nicht allein bin aber jetzt eigentlich
wie auch immer ich bin mir danke sonst
mit denen sie
die palliative betreuung von kindern und
jugendlichen beinhaltet nicht nur das
sterben es geht auch um leben möglichst
viele gute momente und erinnerungen
schaffen und zwar jetzt
magali feiert ihren 15
geburtstag zusammen mit ehemaligen
schulkameradinnen die sie so sehr
vermisst
tatsächlich gibt es für die familie
weitaus mehr zu feiern als nur ein
weiteres lebensjahr
das ist natürlich schon sehr gesundes
und im frühling banken und makler oder
sie schon zu schwer behindert dass man
im so geburtstag feierte jetzt sind
jetzt meinen geburtstag 4
und dass ich ein wunderschönes geschenk
die kinder leben und dabei soll das
sterben was soll man angesprochen seien
mit einer behandlungs vereinbarung mit
rea status etc
aber dann ist das kein thema mehr dann
geht es darum wie kann magali heute mit
ihren einschränkungen die sie hat
glücklich sein und leben und wie kann
die familie gesund bleiben und leben
und irgendwann parat dafür sollen das
magali vielleicht stirbt gesundheitlich
hat magali immer wieder rückschläge
erlebten heute ist ein guter tag auch
wenn sich gegen abend ihre anfälle
häufen
das hellblaue wie stimmt das jetzt für
rui
hier muss einfach schneller
[Musik]
das ist genauso kurz nach unseren
dreharbeiten musste magali erneut
notfallmässig ins spital
zwar ist sie wieder zu hause doch die
krankheit schreitet immer weiter voran
ja